hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game that just finished uh
from the uh
tata still chess tournament 2022. it's a
duba versus vidit and it's uh well it's
just a wonderful attacking and defending
game uh you'll see what i mean by this
so let's dive straight into it there is
quite a lot to cover uh duba with the
white pieces opens with e4 with e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and now not
bishop to b5 uh bishop to c for dubo not
interested in any of that positional
stuff uh he wants to play a real
attacking game and he goes for the
italian game bishop to c4 and he's also
checking if vedic will maybe go bishop
c5 so he can go for the evans gambit or
maybe the delayed evans gambit but vidiq
goes knight to f6 a very solid two
knights defense uh where you guys are
again wondering will we see knights to
g5 again we will not these are very very
strong players and they avoid such
openings for the most part but sometimes
they do happen
so d3 uh and now bishop to c5 it doesn't
want to be left behind in development we
have c3 now preparing some queen set
expansion with b4 a4 and d6 now uh and
now usually uh players just castle here
but uh double goes for bishop to g5 it's
a
the movie is somewhat rare but not
extremely rare uh we have h6 but it
immediately challenges the bishop bishop
to h4 and now uh
well again usually a6 or g5 right away
attacking the bishop r played here but
vidid goes for a5 he just prevents any
queen side expansion that adobo might
have planned
and now we have knight to a3 and this is
a new move here there are some uh games
where again a6 or g5 was played uh so
sorry not a6 where g5 was played uh but
here we have knight to a3 oh yeah also
knight beat the d2 is uh is a known move
and it's a very interesting move because
it was played between uh in a game
between adiban and vidit uh in the tata
still india rapid where adiban played
knight beat to d2 but um it didn't work
out well for him if it won that game uh
so here knight the a3 is a deviation
from that game uh and uh this is now
move eight and it is as of move eight
that we have a completely new game so
yeah he's preparing to bring the knight
over to c2 then we he will have
excellent control of the center knight
is coming to e3 then to d5 or e5 uh and
he's offering vidit to capture it uh and
double his pawn so this is something you
don't just declined it's uh
it's a chance to [ __ ] white's
position so you will do it and it's
similar to something magnus did against
geary so he will have the bishop pair
but he will have a ruined pawn structure
so bishop captures an a3b captures and
now queen e7 uh still uh the side is
still waiting uh with the
the castles uh because maybe uh it will
castle queen side so here uh we have
castle's king set by do both and not
knight to b8 shifting this knight over
to d7 uh we have d4 dual strikes in the
center as village king is still in the
center of the board and now knight b to
d7 uh and now rook to b1 a very nice
move uh putting pressure on the entire b
file if the bishop is developed then the
b7 pawn becomes weak
and it's
also a very tricky move because if black
just continues for example with knights
the b6 attacks the bishop we can play
bishop to b5 check and now black will
have to struggle for moves because c6 is
now impossible bishop captures on c6 and
then we capture the knight on b6 so
there are uh some very tricky lines here
so if it just goes g5 we have bishop to
g3 and he grabs the e4 pawn we have
knight captures on e4 and now dubo goes
queen to c2 now the e file is almost
open which is uh something the dubo
really wants to do the queen and king
are still on on the e file and now what
can uh video do here his knight is
attacked he can defend it with f5 or he
could capture the bishop here capturing
the bishop is a very dangerous but it
can be played i'm just going to show it
because it's a super fun line for
example knight captures on g3 dubo would
capture with the f pawn because you want
to open up this
file for the rook now knight b6
attacking the bishop and now of course
bishop captures on f7 so this is the the
good stuff queen captures knight
captures on e5 opening up a double
discovery here and now queen h7 only
moved to
survive this with black you offer a
queen trade we're gonna decline this
with queen to e2 and now a black wins
another piece but uh for the price of
getting attacked with uh
well just without mercy king to d7 for
example rook to e1 and with this
incredible control of the e and f file
and all of the squares here
it's uh it's basically a draw because um
black can't really do anything and white
doesn't really have enough material to
to finish the game you're probably gonna
keep continuing with queen to e6 check
queen to f6 check queen e6 queen f6 and
you know it's going to be a perpetual so
it's a it's a fun line but uh vidit uh
decides uh that he's going to go for f5
uh maybe uh he can do more than a draw
we have d captures on e5 d captures an
e5 and now rook f2 e1 you don't have to
worry about f4 because then the knight
also hangs so it's not really like your
blundering a bishop on g3 so knight
captures on g3 now we're gonna capture
with the h pawn there's no point in
capturing with the f pawn any longer and
now of course e4 as this pawn is a weak
pawn so we have to advance it we have
pawn to e4 and now dubo of course plays
g4 now you don't have to worry about
capturing the queen is still on e7 and
we want to weaken this pawn so we can
capture this pawn and hopefully take
advantage of its king still being in the
center of the board so with it plays
knight to c5 this is the only way to
keep defending with black because this
pawn will become extremely weak we have
to defend it and luckily dubo doesn't
have a d-pawn or a b pawn to kick away
this knight so here knight to d4 putting
more pressure on f5 and now uh we just
uh play rook to f8 if you play f
captures on g for the knight b3 we
challenge this knight and then it's not
going to be easy for black to survive
this or rather it's going to be
impossible so after 94 rook to f8
and now g captures on f5 we have bishop
captures on f5 the rook now defends the
bishop and here we have rook captures on
b7 a beautiful move by duboff offering
an entire rook but of course this will
not be all that great for black because
if vidiq captures on b7 uh we play
bishop to b5 with check and now what
you're going to do you can go here
because then knight to c6 check picks up
the queen so you have to go to f7 but
now we capture this because the rook no
longer defends on f7 and this is now
officially a king hunt
uh so instead uh video plays uh rook to
f6 now he has control of the of the
sixth rank and he will be able to to
move the king a little bit if he can
play king king g7 he should be much much
safer so here uh the rook is still
hanging on b7 and the dubois could move
it with something like rook to b5 but
that's not how do both plays chess duo
plays queen to b1 he's preparing rook to
beat chess and uh check and he's still
offering the rook so knight captures on
b7 uh queen captures on b7 and now rook
to d8 and now uh it seems that the vidit
avoided all danger and that he's now
ready to finally move the king away from
the e file
but uh well maybe there's not enough
time for that because knight captures on
f5 rook captures on f5 and now rook
captures an e4 and it seems like vidit
is losing the queen uh so the position
is very very delicate you have to choose
choose your next words very wisely uh
because if you just block with rook to
e5 you lose the game on the spot i'm
gonna
show it queen to c6 with check and now
the problem is uh what do you do here
you're going to move the king so now we
play queen captures an h6 with check you
can go to g8 the bishop covers this so
you have to go back queen to h8 to check
and now we connect with the rook on e5
for example king here queen captures
here you've just lost an entire rook
captures captures of course the end game
is now completely winning for vidit uh
he has uh well he's just up a full piece
so instead after rook captures on e4 the
only move uh for vidit is rook to d1
check we have to do this to free up the
d8 square for the black king king h2 and
now only now rook to e5 that's how you
have to play it we have queen the c6
check but now of course we go to the d8
square uh queen to a8 with check king d7
and now bishop to b5 check this is a
it seems almost impossible that you can
survive this with white because look at
this the queen slices over here the
bishop slices over here the rook slices
over here uh but it it seems that it's
possible king to e6
queen to c8 check now king to f6 queen
to h8 check now comes king to f5 this is
uh it's hard to figure out that if this
is a king hunt or a king march is
attacking with the king or or is he
running away
and now the problem for dubois is that
it doesn't seem like a bit it's a
running way but it also doesn't seem
like he's attacking here the position is
a draw and you have to agree to it with
queen to c8 cher king f6 queen to h8 and
now the position repeats itself the
problem is both players are extremely
low on time and they've been very long
time for quite some time and it's only
moved 32. uh so instead after queen to
five dubois just played f3 uh it's
something that you do of uh you know
just cannot go against it is against his
nature to force a repetition like this
with the white pieces uh so he plays f3
but now the position is completely
winning for vidit uh so feel free to
pause the video here and win the game
for vid
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
just crushing crushing move uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is rook captures an e4 uh that's
the the move that wins it seems like a
simple solution but uh if it wins uh
we're we're not going to look any
further so dubo of course uh captures
back with f captures on e4 and now king
captures on e4 also very interesting is
maybe you guys are thinking why not
include the g4 uh with check first it
looks a bit scary but king f4 and this
is perfectly fine there's no way to
continue this stack the king is on a
dark square so we don't have to worry
about anything so yeah instead f
captures an e4 was played and now king
captures on e4 and now what do you play
here uh avidit is now up upon but not
only that he's up the exchange so queen
to a8 with check king to e3 yeah and now
if you continue checking queen to a7
check we're going to play king to d2 and
after queen to d4 with check king c1 is
perfectly fine for black there are no
more checks and you don't have to worry
about anything so after king to e3 we
have bishop to c6 by do both but now
just queen to e5 with check and now uh
well now it's pretty clear that this
game is is just over uh so if you go
king h3 then this is just checkmate okay
trunking g4 h5 checkmate nothing uh
fun for white there so g3 was played by
dubaf but now g4 just taking away the
square from the from the white king
queen to a7 check king to d2 and he was
in this position on move 37 that uh
daniel dubo resigned the game and
another brilliant victory for vidit in
round three of the 2022 tata still chess
tournament so it's a brilliant
tournament so far for him uh winning
against shankland in round one then a
draw against caruana in round two and
now taking don dubo in round three uh
really really an impressive start uh
we'll see if he can continue this as so
far he is um
leading uh with so so lead uh and it if
he continues like this then he will
definitely uh win this tournament with a
great style so here you resign because
after let's say one more check queen f2
check we're gonna play king to c1 now
you're kind of threatening to win the
queen so let's say queen f4 check we
have to force a trade uh but now just
rook d2 you block check and deliver
check and after let's say king g1 queen
to c5 check
and there's nothing more that
you can do here king's gonna move we're
gonna play queen captures on c6 we're
gonna deliver queen to h1 checkmate and
that's it uh pretty much this is not
this is not the only line uh but pretty
much all of the lines uh and uh
somewhere around here all right but yeah
after uh king 32 uh duboff saw this and
of course uh it was in this position
that he resigned the game
so great attacking game great at a
defending game and it just seems that
here after king to f5 dubois could not
agree with himself to go for a
repetition here he played f3 and that's
that's all there is
uh so yeah uh that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it very very nicely played
by vidit uh i would like to thank joseph
henderson frank come see antopolis uh
richard talman and robert youngquist for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
this wonderful event uh until it ends uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day